Sí, la idea es un poco conocerte a ti.
Sé que hemos estado hablando previamente
para detectar, digamos,
la la relación de la de la solicitud con
el con el máster. Sí,
es un poco más que nada para poner en
contexto. En segundo lugar,
ver la malla curricular revisarla, sí,
de acuerdo a lo que te pasé y si lo
pudiste ver. Y en último término,
hablar de la parte económica y la
posibilidad de acceder a apoyos
económicos bien o k muy bien.
Entonces cuéntame un poquito para
ponernos en contexto nuevamente. ¿Uriel,
tú me habías contado algo de que en la
empresa en la que te encuentras así,
a grandes rasgos te resumo que estabas a
cargo de 3 departamentos y el último que
te habían asignado era el de Recursos
Humanos, verdad? ¿Exactamente sí, sí, sí,
bien,
YY digamos cómo cómo es un día a día tuyo,
personas que tienes a cargo,
cómo has llegado a conocernos?
O K Este, bueno, la primer parte,
siendo honesto,
yo creo que seguramente los encontré en
LinkedIn. ¿Este cómo?
¿Cómo es la interacción? Digo, en general,
lo que pasa es que digo es una compañía
japonesa, pero hay como un este,
hay unos headquarters en Estados Unidos,
regionales,
entonces normalmente como trabajamos es
hay una,
hay una planeación anual de Japón que
baja con Estados Unidos y sobre eso
hacemos nuestra planeación.
¿Cuánta gente tengo yo en la parte de RH?
Tengo 5 personas,
tengo un gerente y tengo otras cuatro
personas que están ahí adentro.
Entonces la realidad es que como te decía,
no en un principio, pues no,
yo no tengo un perfil de RH.
Es es la primera vez que me toca como tal
supervisar un departamento de RH.
Entonces no me ha tocado tener como toda
la experiencia acerca de.
Pues las herramientas y las estrategias
necesarias como para reforzar el tema de
funcionamiento de los Recursos Humanos,
no me lo asignaron hace como 2 años. Sí,
hace 2 años y he estado trabajando con
consultores locales.
Este bueno hay tema sobre todo
desarrollar la parte de este desarrollo
organizacional, valga la redundancia.
¿Cómo es el día a diario? Pues hijo,
con la parte que te comentaba de la
planeación anual,
normalmente como trabajamos es este,
desarrollamos como tal ya un plan de
trabajo anual.
Normalmente lo que lo lo que hacemos es
lo trabajamos con base en el esquema de P
D C a S pues nuevamente la compañera
trabaja con una tira de p d c a s que
definimos al inicio del año y sobre eso
vamos monitoreando mes con mes.
Entonces normalmente lo que pasa es en el
en en la actividad mensual,
normalmente al cierre del mes previo.
¿Tengo una Junta con los gerentes de los
departamentos que tengo realizamos,
como el tema de las actividades que
traemos y a partir de ahí vamos viendo
como como prioridades qué temas se nos
están retrasando,
qué otros temas no están llegando?
La realidad es que en el tema de la de la
parte del recurso humano de la compañía,
hoy día si está haciendo una parte del
reto, porque.
Para empezar, es es una compañía activa,
una mezcla de 3 culturas.
Está la parte japonesa porque tenemos
claro 5 japoneses en la compañía.
El Presidente de la compañía y el gerente
general son japoneses,
pero como te decía igual también tenemos
reporte a Estados Unidos.
Entonces este tenemos una mezcla cultural,
hay hay cosas que los japoneses quieren
hacer de una forma,
pero los americanos quieren que ser de
otra forma,
pero el mexicano lo entiende de otra
forma y este y creo que ese es como que
el mayor reto en la parte del recurso
humano. ¿O sea, cómo?
¿Cómo generar las herramientas para poder
facilitar el tema de comunicación y que
converjan esas 3 culturas en un
entendimiento común?
Ese es 1 de los temas.
También es una realidad que a partir de
que llegue a R h.
La compañía a nivel regional trabaja con
Gallup para el tema de de engagement YY
el tema de engagement.
Pues la realidad es que hemos ido bajando,
o sea, no no salimos tan mal,
hace 3 años sacamos si nos hace mal como
3.3 de 5,
pero la realidad es que el último
resultado fue 3 de 5 y el del año pasado
fue 2.7 de 5. No, entonces sí, sí,
hemos sido como en una tendencia
mayormente a la baja.
YY mi percepción es que hay una,
pues hay un reto en la compañía. Vaya,
creo que desde el cómo estamos llevando
hoy día el proceso de reclutamiento y
selección, cómo hacemos el onboarding,
la inducción hasta la parte en cómo
desarrollamos el talento.
Creo hoy día que está muy,
muy desconectado. O sea,
hacemos actividades muy aisladas donde
este, por ejemplo, tiene.
Como 3 meses,
dos meses que cambiamos como el proceso
de reclutamiento,
pero a grandes rasgos tendría nuestro
proceso de reclutamiento. Era muy,
muy básico, básicamente.
¿Era el gerente o el supervisor del
departamento? Era el que entrevistaba,
era el que decidía y ya no.
Entonces no había como un tal como tal,
un proceso de filtro de de habilidades
blandas,
este de comportamientos que la compañía
definiera como un perfil.
Entonces esas cosas son,
creo que las que nos faltan.
Hoy trabajamos muy empíricamente.
YY digo ya para cerrar,
porque tal vez me extendí,
o sea realmente mi búsqueda,
mi búsqueda de de algún tema,
de un de un máster o de alguna de algún
posgrado,
algo que que que me ayude como a poder,
de manera más estratégica,
identificar cuáles son como los puntos
neurálgicos de cada una de esas
actividades.
Que pudieran permitir como que pudiéramos
hacer un cambio gradual, no, hoy,
hoy contesto,
lo que te quiero decir es hoy aparece
como que estamos dando nada más golpes
aislados,
pero no en una estrategia más integral,
donde podamos ir dándole cauce.
¿Entonces es en general,
es como mi día a día,
este cómo se hace la planeación y en
general porque estoy buscando como alguna
opción por estos temas, claro,
digamos como que está un poco
desorganizada esa parte, no?
¿Entonces para mejorar los números,
digamos esto,
entiendo que por ahí tuviste una reunión,
ahora como la tienes todos los bueno,
los fines de meses no fines de meses me
dijiste y han y esto digamos por por qué
ahora surgió?
¿Es por estos números que por la
tendencia a la baja,
porque me dices que hace 2 años que estás
tú a cargo del Departamento de Recursos
Humanos,
entonces por qué ahora y no antes?
¿Cuánto?
¿Cuánto tiempo llevas con esta búsqueda
tú?
¿La busca? Bueno, te digo,
lo que pasa es que, o sea,
dentro de esos 2 años hubo como todo un
proceso de transición,
digamos este hace hace 2 años. Digo,
si si tiene dos tendrá 2 años y medio.
O sea,
básicamente la transición fue porque se
tenía planeada hacerla de esa manera,
pero sin embargo, en meses antes,
un par de meses antes de que sucediera
eso,
la persona que estaba ocupando la
posición de gerencia la o sea, renunció.
Y entonces eso pues el proceso lo hizo
más lento.
Entonces tuvimos que comenzar desde la
parte de volver que toda una persona
inducirla y demás.
Entonces pues te daría en la práctica.
Yo creo que llevamos 1 año y medio
trabajando en ello. ¿Después qué pasó?
Es una realidad que tal vez,
cuando tomamos la decisión de contratar a
la persona que hoy día tenemos,
nuevamente se nos pegó el.
Las debilidades del proceso de
reportamiento de selección,
porque probablemente no,
no seleccionamos como tal a la persona
que tuviera, como todos los conocimientos,
no,
entonces ahí es a donde yo me quedé un
poquito corto,
porque asumiendo que esa persona ocupada
la la parte de la gerencia,
pues la idea sería que debería de tener
como todo el conocimiento para este
desarrollo.
Pero la realidad es que no sucedió así.
Entonces, con base en todas esas cosas,
este.
Es que al final viene como me decía de
tengo que meterme más en el detalle,
tengo que generar como un mayor expertiz
para poder soportar como toda esa parte
de Planeación, el tema de las reuniones,
básicamente es algo que yo tengo.
O sea que lo tenían los otros
departamentos.
Entonces normalmente cada cada mes a
nivel regional tenemos una Junta que
reportamos como todos los resultados y
normalmente lo que yo hago es 1 o 2
semanas. Antes de que suceda eso,
yo hago como un pre check in con ellos.
Entonces la actividad con Recursos
Humanos pues lleva ha de llevar menos de
1 año es una realidad. O sea, sí,
sí ha costado trabajo implementarlo,
pero te diría llevar como unos 7 meses.
Digamos que lo que lo que puedo notar,
según lo que me comentas,
es que digamos lo hay.
Situaciones que los han agarrado como o
te han agarrado un poco desprevenido y no
has estado preparado cuando pensabas que
por ahí sí podías llegar a estarlo o que
podrías llegar a solucionarlo con algo
que se te ocurriera un poco en el momento,
no,
pero de pronto hubo algunos puntos que no
sabías cómo tocar.
¿Cómo es el proceso de selección?
Sí, y te digo, o sea,
al final creo que convergieron varias
cosas. 11 es el tema como de tal vez,
pues la persona que trajimos no tiene
todo el conocimiento.
Entonces después de eso,
la decisión que tomé fue traer a un
consultor YY el consultor, o sea,
medianamente nos ha ayudado.
O sea porque honestamente la parte de
reclutamiento selecciona implementamos
por el consultor, pero.
Pero también el tema de la cultura de la
compañía.
¿En ocasiones hace complicado el hecho
que vengan consultores y lo implementen,
no?
¿Entonces lo que me gustaría de cierta
manera es hoy día, cómo poder desarrollar,
tal vez un poco más este tema de
conocimientos técnicos de estos procesos?
Para que de manera interna lo podamos ser,
digo nada más.
Como comentario a colación es la,
la realidad es que todo el departamento
de Recursos Humanos se se reconvirtió,
o sea,
las personas que yo recibí hace 2 años y
medio, ya nadie me está. O sea,
se han ido saliendo gradualmente.
Los hemos tenido que sustituir.
Entonces hoy día, salvo la gerente,
la demás gente tiene.
67 meses en la empresa, entonces también.
O sea, sí hay un proceso como de cambio,
de de de todo el personal,
y pues eso implica que también ellos
igual pasen por su proceso de adaptación.
Claro, una rotación casi total.
Total, 100%. Entonces a a tu pregunta,
pues sí, o sea,
antes sucedió varias cosas que no estaban
planeadas en el camino y que las hemos
tenido que tomar así como van llegando.
Bueno,
ese es el es el proceso que tocó tener.
¿A ver, te diste cuenta en este momento?
¿Podría haber sido antes o después,
pero al fin y al cabo estamos aquí
precisamente para tratar de ver cómo
podemos solucionarlo, no?
Y cambiar esos números también,
así que entiendo que digamos.
Esta etapa en la que estás investigando
para poder formarte en lo que mejor te
convenga,
tengo entendido según lo que me dices que
pues o quieres al menos empezar cuanto
antes este.
No te diría que cuanto antes,
honestamente, o sea,
sí quiero tomar como una decisión buena o
hoy día sigo trabajando con con el
consultorio,
entonces no es algo que te que hoy te
podría decir, Ah,
este sí me urge y si mañana inicio o
mañana entro no,
pero porque también la realidad es que
este,
la carga de trabajo la tengo que
redistribuir para poder encontrar ese
espacio. Entonces sí,
es un proceso que estoy viendo,
que quiero y espero que suceda durante el
siguiente año.
¿Si sucede en el primer semestre,
excelente,
si sucede en el segundo semestre,
pues digo, qué más da?
¿Pero la idea es que sí,
la intención es que durante el siguiente
año se se haga esto vale, y Por otro lado,
tú esto cómo tenías pensado de alguna
manera afrontarlo a esta inversión,
es decir,
lo haces por tu propia cuenta o la
compañía te apoya? No,
la realidad es que va a hacer más por mi
cuenta.
¿Vale y te estableciste algún presupuesto
o simplemente ahora quieres comparar y
ver qué hay en el mercado? Sí,
la realidad y diciéndote en esto quiero
ver cómo está el mercado este yo como
referencia mi mi perfil es más como la
parte de auditoría de control interno YY
toda esta parte de compliance y hace 3 4
años estuve como investigando en esa
parte tengo una idea,
pero quiero como actualizar y sobre eso
pues tomar una decisión o k entonces
digamos que.
¿Ver el Máster en Dirección de Recursos
Humanos y gestión del talento también
podría ser que de pronto tenga que ver
más con con tu tarea específica o la
digamos el máster o la especialización
que tú quieres estudiar,
es esta porque tú ahora me dices que
haces auditoría y control interno, no?
Bueno,
es que es que ahorita hago de todo
honestamente, claro, la parte de riesgos,
honestamente no, no, ahorita.
¿No es mi prioridad ahorita tomar como un
tema este, si soy honesto,
tal vez te diría estaría como entre un
tema, ya sea como de Recursos Humanos,
gestión de talento o tal vez 1 m b a o
sea podrían ser como las dos opciones,
pero tanto el tema como de de riesgos de
compliance,
como también traigo el tema de de
Comercio Exterior,
esos dos temas ahorita no,
no serían como mi prioridad,
bien de acuerdo?
Y te voy a compartir la pantalla.
Te voy a comentar algo sobre la escuela.
¿No sé si pudiste mirar algo de lo que te
envié o conocías algo de o b s o tú me
dijiste que llegaste a través de busca en
Internet,
exactamente a través de Internet y lo que
me mandaste bien y de o b s qué pudiste
ver o qué te interesó que te llamó la
atención de nosotros?
Yo digo como toda la carpeta que ofrecen,
o sea,
me interesó como esta parte de cómo están
viendo la parte de educación continua,
o sea, y las opciones que manejan. O sea,
veo que tienen como una cartera ahí
interesante este, pues,
tanto de apoyos como de currículo,
de opciones de estudio.
Entonces eso fue lo que lo que me
interesó digo. O sea,
al final creo que hay 1 de los.
De los grandes retos que hay es pues esta
parte que te decía de muchas veces,
no hay mucho tiempo.
Entonces pérame que buscar como opciones
de si pueden ser vías relotas pueden ser
este híbridas.
Entonces creo que todos trabajan
interesantes, todos trabajan en remoto.
Tú que me comentabas que hay japoneses,
hay norteamericanos, hay mexicanos,
trabajan todos en remoto, no, no,
no presencial, presenciales o al menos es.
Al menos estos japoneses no les gusta
mucho el tema de los remoto,
el moto vale y se comunican que todos en
inglés, sí, sí, sí. O sea, realmente,
aunque la compañía esté en México,
la realidad es que la compa, la la,
la comunicación, los reportes, todo,
pues el 90% es en inglés. ¿Bien,
cómo se llama la compañía Honda Trading?
No traiga o k bien, mira,
te comento brevemente algunos datos.
Nosotros como tal nació como la primera
Escuela de Negocios online al 100% en
español, es decir,
nosotros surgimos allá por el año 2006,
cuando ninguno se lo había planteado
hacer enseñanza online.
Y es de importancia destacar esto porque
realmente fuimos pioneros, ser pioneros.
Eso implica que llevamos ya casi 20 años
desarrollando esta metodología.
Y eso ha generado que tengamos muchos
reconocimientos,
lo cual luego de pronto tú puedes llegar
a conocer o investigar sobre otras
escuelas que se les llama a veces escuela
de garaje,
porque tienen todo clases pregrabadas y
han surgido muchas por la pandemia, no,
pero nosotros venimos hace mucho tiempo y
de la mano de quién pertenecemos,
que es el Grupo Planeta.
El Grupo el Grupo Planeta, si lo conoces.
Tiene 3 partes muy importantes,
una es la línea editorial que tiene 75
años de historia y es la número 1 a nivel
Hispanoamérica.
Luego tenemos la parte de
telecomunicaciones con atresmedia,
que aquí en España es dueño de muchos
canales de televisión y periódicos.
Y también bueno,
fueron los que un dato de color
produjeron la serie Netflix,
la casa de papel YY también esa. Bueno,
eso seguramente la la puedes llegar a
conocer varias más también.
Y por último estamos nosotros,
que somos planeta,
formación en universidades,
el cual formamos parte de un holding de
2322 escuelas de negocio,
y nosotros somos la única,
que es 100% online.
No tenemos modelo híbrido, digamos.
Tenemos como partner académico de la
Universidad Barcelona,
que somos la única que lo tiene. Sí,
YY Por otro lado, digamos,
tenemos esta característica que estamos
dirigidas a la alta dirección.
Es decir,
tú encontrarás con que casi el 80% de los
alumnos son directivos de empresas. Sí,
así como estás,
tú te vas a encontrar con presidentes o c,
E o S sí que van a ser tus compañeros y a
la vez los mismos docentes son casi el
60% de esos 450 que ahí te dice que son
practitioners. Es decir, practitioners,
son personas que están en activo. ¿No,
no es como que de repente estás en una
Universidad dónde quien es tu docente?
¿Es tu docente que escribió libros pero
nunca ejerció? Quizás no,
a veces pasa eso en las universidades,
aquí están todos en activo en empresas de
renombre y te van a poner casos de su día
a día para que resuelvan sí y se armen
debates. Sí,
nosotros utilizamos lo que es la la
metodología Harvard estudio del caso.
¿Te suena conocida así, no? Sí, sí,
justo hace que como dos,
3 meses tuvo un como un.
111 diplomado en el itam de y justo lo
hicieron con esa metodología, o sea,
con el foco está puesto tú en que tú eres
el centro y básicamente empieza la la
semana empieza por ejemplo el docente,
dándote algún caso para que resuelvas y
de pronto quien te da el mismo feedback
que es el docente de manera personalizada.
Nosotros tenemos cupos muy limitados y en
esto siempre quiero ser claro. Uriel,
porque eso permite el World Networking.
Sí, es decir,
las personas con las cuales te vas a
rodear, tanto como docentes,
como compañeros,
son personas que son tratadas de manera
particular y a la vez,
luego en Grupo debaten.
¿Entonces eso hace que la interacción y
el intercambio de conocimiento sea mucho
mejor? Sí, Por otro lado,
bueno también comentarte que en cuanto a
lo que son,
reconocimientos nosotros como escuela
como tal.
Tenemos muchos y hay un ranking que es el
QS Stars,
que es el básicamente el que mide a las
escuelas de negocio a nivel mundial.
Esto es como las estrellas Michelín para
los restaurantes. Sí,
es que te dice que en diferentes
categorías tú puede ser catalogado con 3,
4 o 5 estrellas y las 5 estrellas es de
la máxima, el máximo reconocimiento.
Entonces nosotros hay categorías muy
importantes que tenemos esas 5 estrellas.
La metodología en sí mismo,
el online Learning sí tenemos las 5
estrellas.
¿Qué significa que no pierdes calidad por
el hecho de que sea online? Es decir,
estamos un poco mal acostumbrados hoy en
día que hayan aparecido todas estas
escuelas que como te repito,
son muchas clases pregrabadas,
se pierde mucho la calidad,
no tienes contacto con nadie y de pronto
sientes que tiraste tu dinero.
Entonces nosotros en estos 20 años,
casi 20 años,
hemos logrado que estudiar online con
nosotros.
¿Sea casi como estudiar presencial,
porque en realidad lo único que cambia es
eso, el tema de estar en el en el lugar,
pero la interacción que tú tienes y la
experiencia que tú tienes al estudiar con
nosotros genera los mismos o mejores
resultados? Sí, Por otro lado,
lo que es teaching los docentes que
tenemos y la metodología que ya te
comenté que utilizamos,
eso nos hizo tener las 5 estrellas
también, y lo que es employability,
es decir,
la capacidad que tienen nuestros alumnos
una vez graduados.
De si estás buscando trabajo,
recibir ofertas tanto de nacionales como
internacionales en caso de que estés
buscando hacer una upgrade de tu de tu
hoja de vida,
sí o de tu cargo o lo que fuera que
logres ascender en tu empresa y además
aumentar tu salario o el objetivo que te
hayas planteado incluso de manera
autónoma. No,
porque De hecho tenemos una incubadora de
empresas muy interesante que donde pones
tu proyecto y te acompañamos en el camino
del éxito. Bien.
Y luego aparecemos en varios rankings más.
Estamos en ranking El Mundo en la revista
Forbes, en el Financial Times sí.
Tenemos hay muchos máster que están
exclusivamente premiados, sí,
y en el universal,
que es el ranking de los mejores máster
del mundo, también, sí. Por otro lado,
partner académico Universidad de
Barcelona,
tú con nosotros te titulas doble.
No sé si respecto a lo que es la
titulación, los certificados.
Tú buscabas algo en específico o estás
buscando lo que es contenido más allá de
los títulos buenos que te puedan dar este
pues creo que es un híbrido,
te como está en la parte apenas iniciando.
O sea sería sería un híbrido,
pero evidentemente si escuchabas de la
Universidad de Barcelona y sí he visto,
tiene otros másteres interesantes.
Aquí el título doble que obtienes es el
de o b s como tal como Escuela de
Negocios y el de la Universidad de
Barcelona,
que es el respaldo institucional y
académico que nosotros tenemos por estos
reconocimientos que también nos hemos
ganado con el tiempo.
Entonces es una Universidad que tiene más
de medio milenio de historia,
no es poca cosa,
y que a nivel digamos en los rankings de
las de todas las universidades de habla
hispana es la número 1.
Arriba de ella está Harvard,
Oxford y Age y todas las que ya conocemos
de habla inglesa.
Luego tenemos bueno aquí te comentaba
algunos rankings, perdón,
algunos datos de lo que es empleabilidad,
sí,
pero algo muy importante también es la
capacidad de construir una red de
contactos útiles que te genera o b s esto
es un punto para nosotros superimportante
y en lo que 9 y medio así, literal,
9 y medio de cada 10 alumnos recomiendan
estudiar con o b s por este tema,
es decir, tú te de pronto.
A las 48 horas de Matricularte recibes
las credenciales para para acceder a lo
que es el blackboard, el campus virtual,
y allí tienes además de miles de
actividades que se realizan a través de
lo que es la comunidad alumni.
Sí que es la Comunidad que tenemos de
profesionales de alumnos y ex alumnos a
lo largo del mundo.
También digamos tienes acceso a lo que es
el Directorio Alumni.
¿El Directorio Alumni es se sí,
por ejemplo, aquí vienes,
quieres buscar por persona, empresa,
país o Master?
Y puedes buscar al profesional que
quieras de 45000 que ya tenemos hoy en
día,
incluso a través de LinkedIn puedes mirar
en antiguos alumnos sí,
y aquí podemos buscar si quieres en en
México o alguna empresa.
No sé se te ocurre alguna empresa la cual
buscar a ver si tenemos algún ex alumno
Bimbo, Bimbo,
por algo en particular Bimbo.
No, no,
yo sí conozco a a algunas personas de ahí,
pero tenemos, tenemos, mira.
Además viven en varios en diferentes
países, Bimbo, de varios países,
el Grupo Bimbo y estas deben ser
relacionadas,
pero aquí tenemos por ejemplo a b P de
supply change, Roy Andrés, Tatiana,
que es comercial.
Luego tenemos supervisor de planificación
regional, pran, manager,
gerente de logística,
jefa regional de asuntos regulatorios en
Grupo Bimbo y.
Por lo general son cargos gerenciales,
son altos cargos, algún que otro por ahí.
Si ves algún cargo que es medio junior es
porque quizás está siendo alumno
actualmente y está buscando ascender.
Pero nosotros cuando miramos en esto que
esto te invito a que lo revises el
LinkedIn, esto está muy interesante,
hacemos publicaciones todo el tiempo y yo
también en mi LinkedIn también YY te y
algo que tiene muy de particular nuestros
máster que.
No sé si lo has podido ver en sus títulos
previse Life Long learning son máster de
formación permanente, es decir,
tú en el momento en el que te matriculas
tienes acceso a los boot Camps,
a los talleres prácticos desde el momento
en que empiezas,
incluso en el momento previo al máster
que ya te comentaré sobre eso y toda tu
vida. Es decir,
pasas de ser de manera vitalicia parte de
la Comunidad y cada vez que tú quieras
estar actualizándote vas a van a
aparecerte talleres prácticos van a
aparecerte Boot Camps.
Hay algunos que son comunes a todos los
másteres,
otros que son propios del máster que
estás estudiando,
pero la ventaja que tenemos con respecto
a cualquier otra escuela es que es una
formación constante.
La que ofrecemos nosotros no termina en
los 12 meses que duran nuestras maestrías,
porque no son de duración de 12 meses,
sino que siempre que vayas a estar
teniendo que actualizarte en algo,
lo vas a tener ahí al alcance.
Y en caso de que incluso por ejemplo.
De la de lo que hay en la currícula.
No encuentres lo que te pueda interesar o
porque estás buscando algo más específico.
Te pones en contacto con alguien de
directorio Alumni YY seguramente con los
contactos que vas generando te van a dar
ideas.
Vas a seguir intercambiando conocimientos.
Es decir,
te puedo asegurar que esto es un punto
que siempre destacamos porque funciona y
funciona muy bien la red de contactos.
Sí bien, dicho esto,
alguna duda sobre EBS hay algo que.
Y por ahí no sé,
estaba buscando en particular de de la
institución con la cual formarte. No, no,
yo realmente con estos datos me has me
has ayudado mucho bien repasando lo que
es la la malla curricular,
Gabriel coméntame que viste que te
interesó si tienes dudas al respecto de
la misma, yo honestamente,
a esta sí no llegué, Eh, me la mandaste,
pero no, no me metí al detalle,
no la pudiste ver.
1 perdón, yo te mandé esto,
que son 60 páginas.
Claramente no vamos a revisar todo porque
hay de todo aquí. Sí,
digamos es un máster que dura 12 meses,
que cumple con los 60 créditos STS,
que se necesita para ser considerado
maestría,
que ahora digamos cuando vemos módulo por
módulo,
cada módulo tiene un valor de 5 créditos,
son un total de 10 módulos y la tesis
final vale los 10 créditos restantes. Sí,
no es una tesis, perdón,
es un trabajo de fin de máster.
Hay que siempre destacar esa diferencia
porque en realidad es un trabajo que
puede ser grupal,
en el cual se trata de que en un solo
proyecto se se hagan ver detalladamente
trabajando en grupo cada cada cosa de lo
que se vio en los módulos, es decir,
aplicarla en un solo proyecto, sí,
de manera tal que se entienda que que lo
entendieron sí o k luego perfiles que vas
a encontrar en esta maestría.
Mayormente son mandos intermedios. ¿Sí,
tú creo que estarías dentro de lo que
sería el gerente de departamento,
por así decirlo, en ese 26% no? Exacto,
porque mando intermedio.
En realidad estás un poquito más arriba
de eso y luego técnicos especialistas,
también otro otro tanto.
¿Dónde puedes apuntar con esto? ¿Bueno,
siempre van a ser cargos directivos, no?
Nosotros, ya te digo,
somos una escuela dedicada a la alta
dirección YY digamos,
toda nuestra malla curricular está
íntimamente vinculada a el desarrollo de
una actividad directiva y de gestión
solamente de gestión, sino directiva.
Bien,
aquí está un poco más lo de la
metodología que es la metodología Harvard
que te comentaba y como como bien te dije
lo que es.
Y clase en son todas clases en directo,
sesiones síncronas suelen ser
masterclases de 1 hora,
1:30 H YY digamos al tener 10 módulos,
cada módulo tiene una duración de un mes.
Uriel, es decir,
esto empieza en abril del 2026. Sí,
nosotros tenemos esta convocatoria que
ahora yo le preguntaba cuándo quería
empezar por este tema al tener cupos
limitados.
Esto puede verlo usted como una
oportunidad o como sea.
Yo lo puedo ayudar de la manera que que
tenga herramientas, pero sí que estamos,
por ejemplo, en el medio de diciembre.
Sí hay hay una determinada cantidad de
cupos con unos apoyos económicos que no
son los mismos que en enero,
los mismos que en febrero y ya en marzo
le diría que ya no quedan.
En realidad quedan listas de espera.
Entonces,
si usted lo está pensando o
planificándose para el año que viene.
Yo le voy a plantear lo que tenemos
disponible ahora y si lo quiere
aprovechar,
se puede matricular haciendo la reserva
de su plaza.
¿Si nos da el el el comité de admisión,
esa nos acepta? ¿Sí,
porque pasamos por un comité de admisión
antes y el resto lo vamos manejando con
el tema de cómo financiarlo? Sí,
pero más que nada por este tema lo yo le
quería dejar claro el tema de cuándo
quería, cuándo podía empezarlo,
si quería lo de las clases en directo.
Sepa que como le digo,
no es nada pregrabado.
Se graban en vivo y en directo por si de
pronto usted por cuestión de agenda no
puede estar en alguna. Sí.
Suelen ser para Latinoamérica en el
horario de 18 a 21 horas.
¿Quienes suelen tener que trasnochar son
los españoles, sí,
porque lo tienen un poquito más difícil,
pero pero para Latinoamérica está
bastante bien ajustado el horario?
Si porque es horario,
que por lo general no,
no muchos trabajan a esa hora.
Así que, y bueno, lo que le digo,
quedan todas grabadas y disponibles en el
campus una vez fueron emitidas,
en las que se pregraba o k el tema de los
casos de estudio, los debates,
los boot Camps.
¿Hay algo que me quiera preguntar sobre
eso o tiene alguna duda? No, no, no,
eso está claro, todo bien.
Todo lo que son software y simuladores
que vaya a necesitar para desarrollar las
prácticas y las actividades los tiene
incluidos en el precio.
Usted no tiene que pagar ninguna
membresía anual,
ninguna suscripción a ningún programa.
Se los damos todos. Y de paso,
si de pronto hay alguno que otro que no
conozca, va a saber cuáles son los,
las herramientas o los instrumentos que
en ese momento se está requiriendo en en
el ámbito. Es decir,
cuando usted me hablaba de.
Quizás haber quedado un poco
desorganizado,
desfasado en el tiempo o con una
metodología un poco arcaica en el proceso
de selección.
Aquí va a tener no solamente nuevas
metodologías y estrategias. Sí que,
De hecho,
se están aplicando en el día a día,
como le digo por la metodología,
sino que también le vamos a dar todas
esas herramientas para gestionarlas de
manera eficiente. Sí,
entonces entiéndase que nuestros Masters
son 100% prácticos. Uriel.
Aquí no es que usted viene a estudiar una
teoría,
repite de memoria y aprueba un examen.
Todo lo contrario a lo que se imagina es
esto aquí es debates constantes, práctica,
puesta en práctica,
escenificación de situaciones y a la vez
eso conversarlo,
intercambiar conocimiento con los
compañeros, ver, por ejemplo,
si hay otro gerente de Recursos Humanos
en el en el aula, también hacerle.
Preguntarle a ver cómo le está haciendo
en su día a día,
qué qué soluciones propone determinados
casos.
¿Y eso es lo que lo hace más interesante,
no? O K o K sí, sí, sí, sí,
me imagino todas esas similar a lo que ya
tuve experiencia con todo este tema,
todo este tema de la metodología de
Harvard,
y así me compran muchos casos prácticos y
debatirlos exactamente. O sea,
que se siente cómodo con la metodología
ya sí, eso sí me gustó, sí, bien,
excelente.
¿Coordinadores académicos?
Básicamente como yo así le estoy haciendo
conocer un poco las particularidades de
la malla curricular,
el tema del del blackboard que es este
que está aquí,
a lo cual después si quiere le puedo
pasar unos usuarios y contraseña de una
cuenta demo para que entre usted y mire,
pero básicamente es esto,
usted tiene 1 o 2 semanas antes de
empezar el los cada módulo le van a pasar
los horarios de las cuatro Master clases
que tiene por mes.
¿Para que usted se acomueve su vida
personal y laboral junto con los estudios?
Ahora si más o menos sacó cuentas y yo le
dije que cada Master class 1:30. H,
exacto,
y luego el tema de las prácticas y demás.
¿Cuánto cree que puede llegar a
invertirle para estudiar en esta maestría
horas semanales? Le pregunto. Pues digo,
con base en la última experiencia que
tuve,
yo creo que sí le tienes que invertir
unas.
¿6 horas? Yo creo,
al menos esa fue en mi experiencia de
este último diplomado,
aunque lo que me imaginas que con esa
metodología tienes, o sea, te te liberan.
Como casos prácticos,
hay que leerlos y desarrollarlos.
Debes de tener como sesiones previas y
después ya como la plenaria, no,
entonces sí, sí, sí,
son más o menos se estima,
y esto por una estadística que ya tenemos,
es 7 a 10 horas semanales con que le
dedique está bien, es decir,
mínimo 1 hora por día.
Sí o de repente el fin de semana le puede
dedicar más tiempo. Bien, luego están,
como otros datos aparte,
el tema de cargar services,
que es donde tiene las actividades,
estas que yo le he comentado hoy que ya
algunas empezaron, sí,
porque estamos en el pre Master ahora
workshopter, reinvención profesional,
mentoring, Master clases, por ejemplo,
no sé,
guía para la búsqueda de empleo engaged
audient True Power for Storytelling.
Hay hay muchísimos,
son muy interesantes y van quedando todos
aquí los pasados y los presentes y los
futuros se lo van avisando. Sí,
hay preinscripciones por lo general,
así que es es parte de lo que le digo del
Live from Learning,
sí o K aquí está el cronograma, sí,
lo que sí quiero destacarles que usted en
la fase previa al Master,
que esto ya básicamente empezó ahora en
diciembre con algunos Boot Camps tiene 8.
Bootcamps premaster estos 8 Bootcamp
Premaster Uriel, son todos optativos,
ninguno es obligatorio.
Usted elige cuántos quiere hacer,
si no quiere hacer ninguno no pasa nada,
le van a dar un certificado por cada 1
que usted haga de ellos y está todo
incluido en el precio, bien es decir,
si quiere hacer por ejemplo,
en su caso no se quiere.
¿Y por qué le digo que son transversales
a todos los masteres?
Porque son conocimientos que consideramos
que lo deben tener todo profesional hoy
en día si quiere estar a La Vanguardia de
conocimiento, por ejemplo,
sobre todo lo que son I a generativa,
la ingeniería de los proms. ¿Es decir,
cómo preguntarle a las IAS que hoy en día
tenemos yemina y chachipiti?
El pront es como 1 le formula la pregunta,
no, y a veces, digamos,
hay todo una ingeniería detrás de eso
para preguntar adecuadamente y obtener
una respuesta más certera.
No, entonces hoy en día,
si se pone a pensar,
sea en el ámbito que usted se esté
desempeñando, el poder tener un digamos,
una habilidad extra,
que es el manejo de la I a le va a ayudar
muchísimo. Sí,
porque no es que la digamos nos han
querido meter en la cabeza un poco esto
que la I a nos puede llegar a suplantar
en muchos de los empleos,
la realidad es que puede llegar a
suplantar a la gente que no sepa manejar.
I a sí,
entonces si usted por ejemplo hace estos
boot Camps y lo complementa con más
formación.
Nosotros en cuanto a lo que es estas
herramientas,
tenemos muchas cosas para para darle como
como parte de esto sí tenemos el este que
le dio I a generativa hay un curso de I a
de Google también que Google hoy en día,
como usted sabe,
tiene el modo I a con yemenine,
luego tiene organizational well being.
Sí que a este también le puede llegar a
interesar. Bueno,
Building your professional Brand,
pensamiento creativo e innovación data
storytelling.
Si hay son muy interesantes estos
bootcamps.
Así que ya le digo,
lo recomiendo hacerlos cuando usted tenga
tiempo,
le son 2 o 3 semanas cada 1 y no tiene
que dedicarle demasiado tampoco bien o k
luego está el taller introductorio de
capacitación y aquí es un poco para para
nivelar a ver en qué situación está cada
1 de los alumnos y el programa de
desarrollo profesional tiene que ver con
que con un docente lo que van a buscar es
fortalecer y desarrollar habilidades
blandas. Sí, lo que llaman las oskills.
O sea, inteligencia emocional,
productividad,
gestión del tiempo y gestión del estrés,
que ya de por sí no solamente le va a
servir para de alguna manera refrescarlo
para usted YY actualizarse,
sino que también seguramente le vaya a
dar un clic para ver cómo poder
implementarlo en lo que usted está
necesitando hoy en día.
No ahí en la en la empresa que usted me
habló un poco de las softskills aquí se
trata muchísimo. Eso sí,
fíjense que De hecho aquí lo nombramos.
Top kids hardskills lo que lo que
básicamente buscamos desarrollar en cada
perfil de alumno respecto de lo que son
los contenidos. No quiero andar demasiado,
ya que esto lo lo puede leer por su
propia cuenta y no estoy aquí para para
para leerle una facha curricular. Sí,
la idea es un poco que me interesa saber.
¿Uriel,
que es lo que usted un poco ya me lo hizo
saber,
pero si qué es lo que usted considera que
no puede faltar aquí?
¿Para que usted se decida puede estudiar
por 1 o o con otra escuela, no?
Y al fin y al cabo es eso. Pues te digo.
Creo que creo que el tema como tal de
desarrollo e implementación de
herramientas,
sobre todo en el en la parte de
desarrollo de talento,
creo que es lo que más hoy día me
interesa.
¿Entonces digo,
ahí veo que tienes este lo que tienes,
ahí sabes cómo tal procesos y el tema de
herramientas complementarias para la
gestión de RH?
Esa parte como que me me interesa
bastante. O sea, ahí veo por ejemplo,
tienes liderazgo y gestión del equipo,
o sea, exacto, es. Es un tema como muy,
muy importante de este lado.
Exacto, ese el el, digamos.
El programa no se queda en conceptos
teóricos, no,
sino que lo forma en lo que es gestión
estratégica de personas, es decir,
cómo alinear políticas de Recursos
Humanos con los objetivos del negocio,
que creo que es un punto muy importante,
gestión del cambio,
la cultura organizacional, es decir,
acompañar procesos de transformación en
en las organizaciones de una manera
estructurada y humana,
no que luego procesos claves de Recursos
Humanos como usted bien me supo nombrar,
reclutamiento, selección, formación.
Evaluaciones de desempeño, compensaciones.
Sí que aquí, por ejemplo,
podemos hablar de una tendencia que hoy
en día se está hablando de lo que es el
salario emocional,
no herramientas prácticas.
Sí como lo que es el coaching,
la diversidad y la inclusión,
la comunicación interna,
la planificación de servicios. Es decir,
todo esto es lo que son los conocimientos
de tipo estratégicos que son aplicables
al trabajo real, que usted puede,
digamos de alguna manera, aprender aquí.
Sí, luego es.
También puede reforzar competencias
directivas y humanas. Es decir,
usted ya está en una cierta dirección,
pero aquí puede reforzar con los
bootcamps, por ejemplo,
lo que son competencias directivas,
es decir, habilidades de liderazgo,
negociación,
gestión de equipos y gestión de estrés y
mindfulness. Tenemos un boot Camp para,
eso sí,
que son elementos muy importantes para un
rol de Recursos Humanos que se centran en
el en el bienestar de un equipo.
Y luego también.
Tenemos preparaciones para lo que son
certificaciones internacionales del
ámbito que son reconocidas globalmente
por profesionales de Recursos Humanos,
es decir,
nosotros en cada 1 de nuestras maestrías
estamos alineadas con las instituciones
que certifican.
Entonces le da un punto muy importante
para que luego el día de mañana,
si por ejemplo,
sea usted o alguna de las personas que
está dentro de su equipo,
necesita o le hace o le viene bien hacer
una de estas certificaciones por haber
sido alumno, por ejemplo de o b s.
Hasta tiene descuentos y además somos lo
que se llama a t P, es decir,
una institución legalmente autorizada
para impartir los conocimientos que luego
se evalúan para obtener esas
certificaciones.
O KY cumplimos con las horas de vuelo,
digamos que le piden como requisitos para
luego certificarse.
¿Entonces son son todas estas cosas que
usted al momento de tener que digamos
hacer esa comparativa?
¿De pronto dice usted qué está buscando
calidad y excelencia o está buscando
precio, no?
Porque al fin y al cabo,
a veces queremos adaptar algo al
presupuesto que tenemos y no,
no buscamos hacer ese esfuerzo extra que
nos va a ser posicionar muchísimo mejor
en el campo, no,
entonces un poco esto y bueno ni hablar
que lo prepara para para todos los roles
que ya le le comenté. Alta dirección, sí,
responsable, compensaciones y beneficios.
Sí,
es una metodología que además de
adaptarse a lo que son agendas bastante
complicadas a veces.
También no dejamos escapar ningún detalle
al momento de de formarlo en esta
dirección. Bien,
así que no sé si esto un poco responde lo
que está buscando.
Sí digo si me da una buena imagen este ya
nada más. Creo que falta el tema.
Específico como tal de de los costos,
digo,
lo que me da pena es que ya casi inicia
otra Junta que tengo,
no sé si pudiéramos movernos al a que me
ayudara con esa parte y ya cualquier tema
de duda de eso, pues yo tengo tu correo,
igual no,
no ponemos a intercambiar correos por
cualquier duda.
¿Vale comentar la llamada de los 8 Boot
Cams?
¿Están los boot Camp estos que ya le
había comentado?
Sí son 5 boot nada más que están
incluidos.
Y luego lo que es la ceremonia de
graduación, que es aquí en Barcelona,
si eso se llama global Inversion week y
que básicamente es una semana,
el cual incluimos todo excepto los
pasajes aéreos y los y los pedajes.
No me quiero,
no quiero dejar escapar todas estas
herramientas que le incluimos. Sí,
son todo lo que es.
I a sí de administración y de gestión sí.
Son muchas herramientas que para que
ponga en valor realmente el hecho de lo
que estamos ofreciendo. Sí,
SAP por ejemplo,
todas están incluidas bien.
A otro docente lo saltamos.
Le comento brevemente el el proceso de
admisión que se trata de.
Nosotros tenemos un comité el día lunes,
si se quiere presentar y ir por el los
apoyos económicos que tenemos ahora puede
hacerlo. Se asegura una plaza y luego.
El tema de la financiación lo vemos,
sí se puede financiar esto en en partes,
no sé esto. ¿Cómo lo tenía pensado usted,
si lo si lo llegaba a pagar,
él lo hacía al contado o en cuotas? ¿No,
yo creo que están en cuotas,
pero te digo también estoy con la parte
de ir este identificando cuales son los
costos y demás sobre eso,
simplemente para tomar la decisión,
simplemente para para decirle,
para ver cómo le le le planteó después la
cuota, no?
Bien proceso de selección,
esta es la entrevista donde estamos.
Se les solicita documentación de admisión,
que es currículum actualizado, bueno,
allí el curpo RFC en México o el INE,
copia del título que usted tenga y
universitario y una carta de admisión,
que eso le puedo pasar un modelo.
Vamos a la evaluación del Comité,
el Comité nos puede rechazar
tranquilamente, no pasa nada,
no lo exime de presentarse en la
siguiente.
Nos pueden aprobar,
nos aprueban con apoyos económicos o sin
apoyos económicos en el si nos aprueban
con apoyos económicos. Uriel,
ahí tiene que estar seguro de que si
manda la documentación va a ser para
presentarse,
porque si en ese momento no paga la
reserva de su plaza,
es difícil que luego le vuelvan a a
aceptar o con apoyos económicos incluso
sí bien vamos,
finalmente voy a así rapidito porque no
puedo dejar escapar esas partes.
Sí le comento el valor.
El valor de esta maestría es de €7700.
El total incluye la emisión de títulos,
la llegada a México de los títulos
también tanto de o b s como de la
Universidad Barcelona. Por otro lado,
digamos todo lo que son los certificados
por los Boot Camps,
están incluidos talleres prácticos. ¿Sí,
la ceremonia de graduación,
todo está incluido en el precio y cómo lo
puedo hacer? ¿Como le digo,
financiado financiado lo puede hacer con
una reserva de la Plaza con el 10% y el
resto?
Si lo si se matriculara hoy en día puede
hacer 15 cuotas a partir de enero o le
puedo hacer si lo hace,
por ejemplo en enero son 14,
siempre tiene que estar habiendo
terminado de pagar la última cuota en el
momento en el que se gradúa,
que si empieza en abril del año que viene
es abril del 2027,
entonces eso sería un precio oficial
financiado si €770 por ejemplo para la
matrícula y el resto.
En cuotas que ya le digo.
¿De cuánto le quedarían?
Si fueran 15 serían cuotas de 462,
si fueran 14 serían de 495.
¿Ahora yo le pregunto,
este presupuesto está dentro de lo que
usted estima, espera o puede afrontar?
Séame sincero.
Este sí puede ser,
digo al final es lo que te digo, o sea,
todavía estoy como revisando opciones,
pero digo y está más o menos en lo que
tenía en mente, está como lo que tenía,
más o menos vale. Por otro lado,
los apoyos económicos a los que podemos
apuntar para el día lunes,
si se quiere presentar es descuento por
fecha de matrícula 21% por perfil,
estos solo damos nosotros un 5% y.
Podríamos ir a buscar un 10% si podemos
meterlo en un comité de empresa que este
o tiene un 10% más y le queda en €5200,
es decir,
estamos hablando de que podríamos estar
buscando que le den apoyos económicos por
un valor de €2500 2015, sí,
2002 €1500 que es mucho dinero,
no sé si usted se maneja con dólares
pesos mexicanos o quiere hacer la
conversión, no sé más o menos la tengo,
o sea como unos 100000 pesos eso.
¿La reserva de la plaza con cuánto lo
puedo hacer?
¿Con €520 sí y esto te estoy hablando del
lunes no?
Y cada cuota le termina quedando en lugar
de ser 495 como era el inicio,
le quedan 30012112,
si lo ponemos en pesos mexicanos pueden
ser como unos.
6000 pesos, sí,
6690 me aparecen aquí y la inscripción es
con 520.
Ahora tengo una propuesta para hacerle,
yo sé que igual ya me lo dijo,
está en una etapa investigativa, no,
no tiene nada seguro quiere comparar,
eso me queda claro,
ahora se lo tengo que proponer porque
también digamos de alguna manera,
si si usted tiene la posibilidad que
alguien le diga que se puede ahorrar algo
de dinero o puede reservar algo más
barato,
a mí por lo menos me gustaría que me lo
dijeran.
El usted puede rezar la reserva hoy en
día por tema de que estamos en un mes
festivo y entendemos que mucha gente
prefiere a veces guardarse para los
regalos de Navidad,
puede reservar la plaza con un 5%.
¿Qué significa esto que usted con 5575
puede estar reservándolo?
Sí, y luego se le traslada cuotas,
que la verdad es que no,
no le imprime demasiada diferencia,
porque en lugar de ser de 312 es de 329,
entonces en lugar de ser 6690 = 7055
pesos, se reservó,
se aseguró una plaza con este valor si el
Comité lo aprueba,
porque siempre estamos supeditados al
Comité, pero al menos.
Pudo reservarse una plaza que va a
empezar oficialmente en abril del año que
viene,
que estimo que más o menos es un plazo en
el cual usted ya tendrá algo determinado
YY nada es eso, es decir, es decir,
si quiere verlo en enero, febrero, marzo,
aquí estaré.
La propuesta que tengo para hacerle hoy
es esta que tengo aquí y yo se la voy a
pasar por escrito.
Y usted me deja dicho cualquier cosa, sí,
sí, hagamos así, mira,
ya va a empezar mi Junta, discúlpame, sí,
pero.
Pero te agradezco todo,
todo el detalle de explicación, o sea,
sí mándamelo.
Como te dije desde un inicio,
la realidad es que no. O sea,
si hoy día me dices, oye,
si lo quieres apartar para este abril,
yo te diría no,
porque la realidad es que ahorita no
estoy ni ni ni en el punto como de
garantizar que pueda tener las 10:12 H a
la semana.
Entonces sí quiero embarcarme en este
proyecto cuando.
O sea que sí esté con los tiempos,
porque justo fue parte de la experiencia
que tuve en el diplomado que pasé y o sea,
y la realidad es que ese diplomado lo
pasé haciendo los trabajos a las 1:02 h
de la mañana.
Entonces este no quiero hacer eso este,
pero pero con toda esta explicación ya me
dejas más claro el panorama de lo que
incluyen de los costos este de los
tiempos precisamente.
Para sobres organizarme estos periodos
que hablabas de de ingresos son así nada
más.
Cada año no tienes como 1 a mitad de año,
o sea siempre tu proceso inicia tipo
digamos noviembre para que inicies en
abril y así es, cada año son semestrales,
es decir,
nosotros el último que tuvimos es el de
octubre o k que la la convocatoria empezó
en mayo,
que fueron ocupando plazas y mucha gente
a ver.
Entiendase que, por ejemplo,
las aulas no pueden tener más de 50
alumnos.
Si las aulas tienen más de 50 alumnos se
desdobla el máster y terminan haciendo
dos,
lo cual ya después no podemos tener más
porque tenemos un número limitado de de
docentes,
no son 450 y tenemos 40 másteres.
Entonces saque la cuenta,
no nos alcanza para todos, pero sí que,
por ejemplo, la de abril empieza. Ahora,
mientras más se tarda en decidirse,
le termina saliendo más caro.
Por eso nosotros somos muy claros en esta
parte.
Y ahora, de repente,
usted no tiene tanta prisa y o tampoco la
cuestión económica,
no le imprime demasiado esa diferencia y
permite, o sea, quiere pensárselo bien.
No hay problema,
puede podemos verlo en enero de nuevo,
a ver qué números tenemos,
podemos verlo en febrero y si no quiere
para la de abril,
luego tenemos la de octubre en la de
octubre.
Suele en cada una de las convocatorias,
ya le digo, Uriel,
que suelen aumentar un poquito los
másters. Por ejemplo,
este máster que está a 7700 ahora estaba
a 7500 en anterior.
Aquí, aquí en Europa,
€200 no hay diferencia,
pero sé que en otras,
en las economías nuestras de
Latinoamérica, suele ser una diferencia.
No depende cuánto 1 de pronto pueda
afrontar como presupuesto.
Quizá usted no tiene un problema.
Entonces, Por otro lado le digo,
este máster puede estar en los 8000 en la
convocatoria de octubre y las ayudas no
pueden digamos, pueden no ser las mismas.
Sí,
entonces lo que a nosotros nos dicen del
del 21%, del 5% y tal.
Que es algo que nos cada semana nos pasan
un un nuevo detalle de de lo que se puede
hacer o no,
entonces está constantemente
actualizándose,
por eso es que no le no le puedo
garantizar de pronto si esto pueda no no
ser tan bueno para futuro en cuanto
precio no te preocupes eso estoy
consciente.
O sea yo lo que te diría Ahorita porque
me tengo que ir es.
¿Qué te parece si hablamos tipo en marzo?
En marzo me das más claridad,
o sea ahorita en abril sería una mentira
decirte que podría ser una opción,
pero creo que el de octubre puede ser una
opción.
Nos podemos hablar en febrero o en marzo
y sobre eso ir vislumbrando cómo están
las cosas YY yo ya podre tener más
claridad. ¿Te parece? Sí, claro,
que pase toda esta época un poco a
ajetreada no también, y ya con eso,
con eso pues vamos aterrizando las ideas.
En sí yo le paso en limpio,
le voy a pasar dos, dos correos, Uy.